dues Rob would off he's from NASA and Y
Combinator he's the director of data
Sciences for the IT NASA JPL laboratory
and Y Combinator startup founder he
founded NASA's inaugural data science in
computer lab where his team applies new
technologies to strategic problems
across the agency that enable scientists
and engineers to better interact with
information prior to joining JPL when i
founded several successful technology
startups and a JP ladies led Department
of interplanetary data visualization
technology and led space station systems
engineers for the experimental opie ALS
laser communication satellite so let's
welcome Rob Austin Thank You goggie and
thank you everybody for stopping by this
talk so who's excited today this is the
Python community we're in San Francisco
where in Facebook's headquarters this
this is the place awesome and as that
excitement wayne's when you're sick of
this talk a lunch they asked me to tell
you is back in building 18 where we
started so we'll try to get you out of
here on time for that so what I'm going
to talk about today is some of the work
that we're doing is at NASA's Jet
Propulsion Laboratory in Pasadena
California so on on the other side of
this great state and we're going to talk
about a data scientist exploration of
the unknown and we're going to define
dark data just a bit so why don't we
kick this off with a little video
alright so what we're showing there is
is we're we're doing all of this
exploration and of course that
exploration what that comes back to us
as our zeros and ones it's the data that
we're bringing home that we have on the
other side of that pipe not being able
to send our astronauts out to the edge
of the solar system just yet we're
looking at that data and so we've been
doing this for quite some time so we're
exploring the universe and that
exploration is bringing home data and
it's bringing home a lot of it so what
we're going to look at is how NASA how
we're enabling NASA to uncover and act
on what we call the dark data that's
hidden and stored around our laboratory
we're going to look at some things like
how we can present and share that data
like this inside of our laboratory and
how when we visualize and empower our
engineers to use that we can have some
really fun and engaging ways of looking
at in seeing that data live and in
action so the situation then that we
started looking at is our deep space
network is connected in an array of
satellites all around all around our
planet and they're reaching out and
communicating with our solar system
explorers which are now passed out past
the edges of our solar system we have
these located in three locations spread
at about 120 degrees around our globe so
regardless of how the earth is rotated
we can still reach and communicate and
pull data home from those explorers when
that data comes home it's of course
processed in our local data centers here
but we've now extended that so we can
elastically immersed and process that
data in specific clouds so we really
have a powerful infrastructure that we
can build upon and this is really
important today because the data that
we're bringing home is coming back
faster and faster scaling by the
communications distance what started
with micro bits per second back in the
1960s is now increasing using things
like faster bands of radio frequency
communication and now moving up into the
laser communication realm as well so
just like the fiber optics we have on
earth we're extending those out into
space they're free space laser comm but
it's just like the high speed that we
all wish we can
get here at home and this is really
happening today advancements in
communication technology through
experimental payloads like the opals
project that we that we've been working
on and is currently on the international
space station getting ready for its
first laser communication downlink from
space and this is really moving quickly
this is about two weeks ago laser
communication
SpaceX Falcon 9 rocket it's now about
400 kilometers above our head moving at
about 26,000 miles per hour attached to
the International Space Station and
there she was after she left our launch
vehicle a couple weeks ago so this is
the state of how we're advancing our
data today and we've been working on
this for quite some time this is a
picture for one on one of the early
Apollo missions where we had operators
in Houston in this case looking at some
of the the raw bits of telemetry that
we're coming home and we've been growing
on this to build into our mission
control today which is still very much
alive and well this is a picture of
Mission Control Houston in Texas of
course where our operators are
controlling the International Space
Station and some of our explorers around
arm around our planet and around the
solar system and with our data science
hats on we took a look at the landscape
and we wanted to see just what kind of
data do we have inside here and we
looked at all the official systems that
we had and we counted about 209 data
sources that we're using to make this
possible these are 209 databases or data
stores that we're collecting all the
information necessary to do some really
out of this world kind of stuff but when
we think about that a little bit more
and when you think about your
organization we've all got our official
data stores but what about what's not
documented right who wasn't satisfied
with the existing solution I see some
heads nodding and and you created your
own solution right you've got that
capability to do that and if you don't
have the tool you need that you'll find
that solution and what we think of when
we look around our organization and I'm
sure many of yours as well is a
something like this top men working on
it right now so we've got these move on
Jules of our data top men
right we may have stored them archived
and locked them up but what could we do
if we knew what was at there hopefully
we're not spoiling the movie
right so that success
to our epic theme today which is this
and does anyone know what this is a
rendering of yeah someone got it for the
first time this is a scientist rendition
of dark matter okay and does anyone know
what dark matter is though I asked
because we don't and if someone up there
would like to shed afterwards we would
love to hear about it but this is an
active area of exploration for us right
this is the majority of the known
universe and we're learning more about
this every day it's all around us but we
still don't know exactly what it is and
when we take this analogy home to us
what do we see in the dark data around
our organization we know it's all out
there we know there's all sorts of
information we've been locking up but
what percentage of that is our universe
in your unit universe okay so to define
that dark data is the data all around us
that we can't you today we we know it's
there we think it might be there but we
can't use it and why can't we use it
well for a variety of reasons perhaps we
can't find it data discovery is one of
the big problems that I think we're all
faced with today but perhaps we can find
it but it's in some obscure format and
we can't quite interpret it or maybe we
found it interpreted it but it's so
large we can't process it or all these
other hurdles that stand in our way from
unlocking some of the crown jewels of
our our world around us and I think the
fundamental crime here is is when we
can't understand all this information we
can't imagine right we can't think about
well if we could combine these pieces
then we can go a little bit further in
our exploration and this is something
that's really important to up to us this
is a challenge that on April 23rd the
NASA Administrator gave to us and to
paraphrase if the speech if our species
is to survive indefinitely we need to
become a multi-planet species species
and Mars is a stepping stone to other
solar systems this is a huge challenge
okay and we've got some data to draw
from to look at how we've done this in a
pack
asked and how we can do this more
successfully in larger scales in the
future if anyone saw our curiosity rover
land in 2012 and in August that's
successful we have got two Rovers
driving on the surface of the red planet
today we're not stopping there we're
planning for a return of another version
of rover we're calling Mars 2020 that's
supposed to land launch you guessed it
in 2020 and that's going to further our
exploration to look at more types of
more types of information on that planet
to learn more about what it's made of
how its evolved and how habitable that
maybe for for the future we're looking
at larger missions to like Mars sample
return not just putting things on the
Red Planet but when we drop them having
something that can actually come back to
bring samples home to really explore
further and to take this to the realm of
science fiction we're looking at in the
next 20 years thinking about how can we
really put men on the red planet and how
can we use all the data that we've been
collecting for the past 40 or 50 years
in this case to help make these missions
successful so as our first step towards
a solution RIT sitio pose the question
of after exploring for all these decades
what unfound discoveries line the data
that we already have right if we could
look at that and interrogate that in new
ways what's possible and the first
stepping stone towards a solution to
that is all of you it's us it's the data
scientist it's the person that can look
at the data that we've been pulling home
and hypothesize what might be possible
right that's what's key about the
science in our titles it's it's the
ability to fail to ask questions and to
try to do things a little bit
differently and what's innate in that is
is the experimentation and ultimately
the exploration at home that lets us
explore further elsewhere as well and
when we look at a little bit why this is
I think the right time for us to be
solving these problems we've got a lot
at our disposal today we've got a
tremendous amount of tools the software
the libraries that we can use right out
of the gate help
just move really fast we have these
interpreted languages for the
exploration piece where we'll start
we'll start writing and interrogating
our data before we quite know where
we're going with it we can move fast our
tools allow for that for that design
cycle we have these active communities
at home to help us when we're out
exploring abroad and scalable cloud
computing and storage so regardless of
how much data we have or what we need to
process that infrastructure is available
to us that's no longer a problem if we
can visualize the largest datasets
properly we can then communicate to the
public to our peers to our colleagues
why this is important and finally with
some of these open source tools we have
I think we're all connected we're all
part of a larger community and we're all
in this exploration together okay so
back to the data scientist at hand what
we're trying to do as we explore for the
data that we have is two key things
we're first trying to liberate the dart
the dart data this is the data that we
can't use right now and when that's been
liberated we're trying to enable our
engineers so that their expertise can be
applied we know we're never going to
know more about the data that someone
spent their whole career collecting but
if we can help them move that much
faster we've done a service to everyone
so to that first key piece on liberation
it all starts here right this is where
our data comes home as we're exploring
we can process that in our local data
center and as needed we can elastically
burst up to really have the compute
power that we need one liberation
example is where all of our Mars imagery
from our last three Rovers are now
accessible through an endpoint JSON JPL
nasa gov and this lets us do some really
powerful things right away right we can
spin up our favorite edit or whatever
that may look like and we can import a
simple library pull down that URL and
then a couple blocks of code will get
all of the Rovers all of the the days or
the stalls that we've been on Mars then
we can look at all the images too and
right inside of that iterative
exploration notebook we can now start to
view these these images and this is now
a stepping stone to explore further to
you interrogate the imagery to run image
processing on this to start helping
other ideas and other algorithms really
fuse with this data that we've been
collecting really lowering that barrier
now when we look around our organization
and I think most organizations what
makes this challenging is this
architecture that's evolved over the
last five or tens or more years of
closed silos everyone's how to create a
data system they've had to create it for
specific purpose they've been budget and
schedule constraint and they haven't had
the time to really build out maybe the
rich API is that we'd all like to see so
we find these clothes silos all around
us and when we try to look at some of
that data it's just not going to happen
unless we really know how to get in
there today this takes the form of a
couple other prohibiting factors as well
wear a lot of applications that we have
to deal with have been designed for
human consumption but for Rican sumption
or reuse by our code as a data scientist
that wants to take that further it's
just not there it's only for some humans
use through some predefined interface or
lastly what about those obscure
connection strings that maybe you had
written down in a notebook somewhere
sometime years and years ago right we
don't have access to that name anymore
and this is locking up our data so how
do we talk with that well I'm going to
look at three simple approaches that we
found fairly successful there's this
greedy solution of exploring for more
data there's this wise solution that I
think everyone's given us this tip will
you know it's not the data it's the
problem and this last solution will look
at is exploring for questions a little
bit different now to this first approach
exploring for data ideally we would love
to have API it's already accessible but
in some case cases we just don't have
that so to find the data that's all
around us we might explore for it we
might find some pieces of data or a
database around our work and we're going
to get excited we'll see data and we'll
think about what can we possibly to with
that but what I think this is missing is
it's not quite the point to just find
our data because data is a means it's
not the end
the data did not come home for for a
specific purpose a purpose was found or
created and the data came home for that
so our data maintained errs are often
not the folks that can help us really
derive value out of that information so
that's what takes us to the next
approach where we explore for problems
right we explore around the organization
and we find problems that are actively
being looked at and things that need to
be addressed today when we find them we
can look at starting to integrate some
of our solutions to these existing
problems and where I think this mrs.
some of the tremendous value we can
provide is where people are already
working on these problems and they've
been address for quite a while we start
to increment and incremental successes
are wonderful but I think with some of
these new tools or some of the tools
were already using today we can really
revolutionize that okay we can explore
for questions and this is where we take
a slightly different approach where we
explore for these ideas we find fairly
often in our organizations there are
these long-standing questions that
people have been tossing around or crazy
ideas that they've been suggesting for
years one of the orders we finished with
recently had been asking a question for
over ten years and they hadn't seen an
answer so as we explore and find those
questions bringing in some new
technology we can rapidly prototype and
reset those expectations right like it's
2014 we have so much available to us
today we can solve these extremely
rapidly on our team we have this
philosophy where if we can't solve a
problem in two weeks or less or at least
make substantial progress on it we might
not be ready to solve that today because
we want to find the largest possible
impact that we can provide to our
organization and this can be really fun
in the process too now it's this
question I'm looking for questions that
connects us with these larger
communities this is a hackathon we
engage with recently called hack tech in
santa monica and down in Los Angeles
though I think over 1,200 people showed
up and these people are coming in to
collaborate and work on tools and share
what they've accomplished in this case
in 36 hours and we can follow a similar
pace
we can do this by looking outside of our
org how many people visit hacker news on
a regular basis yeah these are places to
find out what's what's available to us
where you can look at the see what's
ready to be implemented today see some
of the great work that our colleagues
are doing we can bring that in there are
other places to look too there's a data
version of hacker news that's been for
called today to tau where you can visit
this today and find all sorts and
technology that's really ready if it's
not ready for application it's ready for
a prototype it's ready to help reset
some expectations and even read it there
is real information that we can use
today so knowing what's out there is
really important when we know what's out
there we can solve these problems
together and continue exploring for more
questions so we have this philosophy of
exploring for questions or questioned
farming this is something we learned
from jer thorp a fairly prolific
designer in New York who uses his
visualizations and his data outreach to
to pull in more questions to engage more
people and to find a lasting impact that
he can have so what's an example of that
well if we look at our curiosity rover
that gets packaged up tightly into one
piece and we've had thousands and
thousands of people working on this
piece this is a combination model of our
sky crane with the rover folded up
inside and when this is constructed with
thousands and thousands of people we
think about our organization as a
collective brain there are all these
lobes from structural engineers to
electrical thermal command and data
handling and all sorts of disciplines
and we want to make sure that our labs
brain is healthy and when we started to
look at a problem like this some folks
came to us and said hey I've got this
data on some of the capabilities and
skill sets what do you think we could do
with this data well right away that's
that's not connecting directly with a
sponsor that was someone holding the
data and there's not much we can do
without some serious approvals before we
go into that sort of approach so that
was not a successful start for us
someone else in came to us and said well
I'm not an owner of the data but I have
a problem and I want to know how healthy
my lobe is and we started talking to
some folks about how he could possibly
analyze that they said well we wait a
minute that's a real problem we've been
looking at that for a while this is how
we we approach and this is our solution
to that problem and so we explored a
little further and we heard this idea
someone was asking what if we could see
the brain evolved what if we could see
the capabilities and skill sets from
year after year after year connect and
evolved and see where things changed and
what if we could see that all in one
place the data we typically we see quite
a bit that these projects start with
might look something like this and to
look at evolution in a workbook it's a
little challenging so we thought a
little bit outside the box where we had
seen other approaches to this type of
evolution approach and so this is a
simple Sankey flow diagram that the
colors are washing out a little bit but
it's connecting one edge to the next to
show how something has evolved from one
point in time to the next and what we
can do after we have this idea is we can
fire up our trusty notebook we can
ingest that data quickly and we can
start experimenting we can start looking
at how we can connect our data with that
visualization technique and it's what we
did was we quickly pull that in present
in that shouted back to the person who
opposed the idea and they said well
that's really interesting maybe we could
take this a little bit further and we
started evolving on this question
together eventually coming into what's
now showing a flow diagram that our
leadership can see of how their
capabilities have evolved from year
after year after year and this is now
entirely automated and available on the
web for them to really interact with
engage with their data and so having
liberated this we can show them other
directions that they can take it and
farm for more questions so one of the
other questions that comes up after you
have some successful demonstrations of
what's possible is what about this what
about my data what if we could connect
that in other ways
or what about if we could connect that
silo and what we start to see pretty
quickly is people are interested in
these connections it's the connections
that let us do some really substantial
things today and so what this leads us
to pretty quickly is the ability to
graph our data using graph databases to
tie things together in brand new ways
and this is where we find some really
interesting permutations on how we can
explore for new data and when we do this
properly we're using the neo4j web d3
ruppel here it becomes really responsive
it becomes really interactive this is
looking at some of my personal data here
and it's it becomes really engaging once
we've graphed this we can interrogate
challenging questions at that graph
right an example of how this ties
together then is we typically start with
the question and we start to find some
areas where that data might exist for
that question and and there's always
these new data sets that we find along
the way that's some of the target data
and at the rate that new data is coming
home it's materializing all around us
all the time right and that's where at
the center of that when we can start to
connect these pieces together that's
where we find some really brand new
value in one example where we took this
last project a little bit further was
where we took some of the geographic
data and where we had been recruiting
and finding these lobes of our brain and
we overlaid that on a heat map right and
we can show our leadership who really
understands the context of this data but
now we present it to them in a slightly
different way we can overlay perhaps our
strategic universities on top of that
and when we put this in a place where it
can be fully automated and animated we
can now let them feel like they're a
part of it and they can touch and feel
and interact with their data and where
we're going to finish here so we're
looping through some of the
organizations that we have and as we
close in on one in particular we'll see
where these red circles which are
strategic schools do not overlap with
some the blue circles which which is
where we've been pulling those lobes
from and you can see right right in the
men
there there's one mismatch the largest
blue circle doesn't have a red circle on
it and these folks that understand that
the leaders the experts that understand
the data when we can present this all
this tabular or dark data that they
hadn't seen in this way they can start
to make brand new conclusions right and
we empower them to make those
conclusions and so sitting at the center
of this web of data all around us we're
trying to connect more of these pieces
and connecting your dots lets people see
things in brand new ways and is this
these webs start to grow as your graph
starts to grow that's where we can
liberate much more dark data now once
we've liberated we want to enable them
and when we think about enabling but we
think about in our organization is we've
got some of the smartest people that
I've ever met working all around us and
our expertise looking at their data for
the first time is never going to compare
to what they've been learning for years
and so we have this chasm them between
their expertise and their data and we
want to close this so again what we find
is when we bring in some new technology
when we bring this in from the outside
right in the middle there we find some
low-hanging fruit we find some some
marriages between the tools that it
already exists and the questions the
idea is that the crazy concepts that we
can tackle pretty quickly and that's the
role that we see of our data science
team inside the organization um some
tools that I think we all love that make
this especially approachable or some of
the frameworks that we can pull in right
away what makes this challenging a
little bit though is if anyone's ever
tried to configure Matt plot lib without
I force someone about a strong technical
background it can be a little
challenging there's a lot of help on how
to configure this on your machine so now
that we have some prepackaged
environments that help us use this right
out of the box this helps us move that
much faster those that many fewer
hurdles to connecting our experts to our
data I'm getting to use a high level and
interpreted language like this combined
with the repple being able to run and
execute our code remotely and pulling
that all the way all the way to our
browser gives us some really awesome
capable
letís today this is something that
really empowers us now we can't quite
use all the publicly available sites we
we have controls in our data as do many
of you we can't push our data out here
but thanks to the open source community
and how we can all collaborate and tie
together we can pull this inside we can
pull this inside and we've done so so
people can share they can look at our
notebooks and we can securely
collaborate on our in on our internal
projects in our internal code now as
we're working on in defining these
projects there's a quote that I think is
really important to keep in mind and so
this is something drew Conway said and
what I think he means why this is that
the answer is not always in the
algorithm right we have to engage with
those around us this is where we find
lasting and and sustainable value and
one of the ways that we find is really
effective of course at taking some first
steps through here is through
visualization it's all about how we
present this that starts the
conversation so we can start climbing
further up in that tree and we can take
a traditional approach we can create
something that may have that they may
have seen before but when we're doing
this we want to be careful to that we're
not showing them that we have the
answers and some simple modifications to
a chart like that can show them really
easily write that we're not showing them
the exact answer but we're helping them
look at things a slightly different way
and so engaging first and helping them
answer their questions has been really
powerful powerful for us and this is
something that as of a few merges ago is
now integrated into the ipython stack so
we like that quite a bit I would also be
remiss if I was up here without showing
the latest XKCD which is an entirely
true of four-year degree in orbital
mechanics is not a not enough to stay on
top of that um so as we're moving in
this direction something that Jason
touched on before is the Cadillac of
presenting or visualizing our date on
the web today
really t3 there there are some great
projects in the work in the Python
community but I think this is still the
Cadillac and so we use this quite a bit
this helps us create really compelling
visuals create them responsibly and
write in a web browser and that's
important so people can touch them
without having to install or jump over
any further barriers to touch this is
the course theta t 3 showreel and so
this is something we can start using
today too we might start with a data
frame and pandas from whatever data
source be pulled from and there's this
there's a Python Vincent library that in
that interfaces directly with ipython
which will compile to this Vega it's a
JSON descriptor language which will help
us create a d3 stream graph which we can
pull rights right inside of our notebook
so with one more pip install and and in
an import we can start to use that
library to create really beautiful
visuals right out of the gate and what's
great about this is it helps us
prototype right in our notebook for
something that we can connect with d3
visualization in a later iteration of
the project and that's often when we
start stepping outside of our notebook
where when we start with some data we
start with this really compelling
workflow of being able to ingest that
right into our iterative exploration
environment and we can move back and
forth we can try new things and iterate
and where we can take this to create
some restful interface that's where we
can do really interactive in empowering
things in the browser that have
connected from this workflow that we
know and love on the back end and that
ties our data all the way to our user
that's how we can really enable them now
for one last example to pull all these
pieces together how we can make a
difference with this after we pulled our
data home from space through the DSN to
through our cloud will have that disease
that our engineers can see in touch with
their tools but when we're exploring for
questions one question that came through
was what if we could interact with all
of the data that we pulled home from our
Rover and what our engineers were asking
for what they really wanted was
something like that something like
Google Finance where they could search
for any telemetry Channel and once
they've once they've found that they
could plot that and by bringing in some
new technology to that stack we've
created something like this and so this
is a tool that our engineers are using
today in their browser where they can
search for any its telemetry Channel and
normally there are some more descriptive
names when it's used internally and
after they've selected that they can
look over all the data points that we've
ever pulled home and when they find an
area that's especially interesting they
can zoom all the way in to look just at
that point in time on the surface to
really interrogate and understand and
this connects our experts directly with
all the data that they've ever pulled
home and this is something that really
empowers them today and after showing
this to some other engineers another
idea came through and it was if now that
we can interact and touch our data
points what if we could get even closer
and I'm not going to show you what some
of our other colleagues are doing with
the oculus today but one of those
endpoints where that data's available is
all the imagery that we pulled home it's
it's public information it's accessible
online and after liberating that in
putting that in the cloud in a web
browser so you can interrogate and
search for any image that are overset
pulled home so we can facet on different
types of cameras different parts of the
rover and exudes extra an extremely
responsive way we made this tool also
with reuse in mind so as you're typing
it's helping compile restful api queries
so you can embed this in other tools
possible by having liberated yeah we
haven't filtered that yet we'll see if
anybody in the rooms an expert on that
so this takes it back to a restful api
with a format that we're all comfortable
consuming right and what we can do is
all these pieces start to tie together
in that graph or in this web that we've
created to empower folks to really let
them when they find a data point they
want they can touch it they can look at
the image they can feel like like
there's no barrier between their
expertise and their data so to pull that
back to the dark data that we've been
working to liberate for that dark data
we're looking for those questions we're
looking for the questions that have been
long-standing that we can solve with a
new approach or a radical new idea today
and it's the people around our
organization that helped make that
possible when we can enable their
expertise to interact with their data
and brand new ways then we've been
successful so to summarize to liberate
your dark data to enable your engineers
I think we can grow data science
together I think we can be incredibly
successful at that and I think we can
have a lot of fun in the process so
thank you for sitting through and I'll
be here for a few questions or you're
all free to head back to 18 for lunch
thank you
you can shout it out if you want or we
can hang out after cool so can you talk
a little bit about the scientific data
solutions you use the data formats or
what what what is NASA or JP know what
do they rely on you know in my work I
work with a lot of floats float data an
American test data kind of analogous to
the type of sensor data you have right
sharing except it's it's on earth but do
you find that like solutions like Hadoop
or stuff available Amazon ec2 is that
not enough to solve the sort of load of
10 million floats and do some regression
or do some machine running on it do you
find barriers there yeah that's that's a
very good question there are barriers
all around so scientific to data HTF for
hdf5 not cdf that's kind of the bread
and butter of science right NASA isn't
created our data archival and access
centers which are distributed around the
country which are collecting that data
and scientists can go to those locations
to analyze their data as this scale of
those data files is growing its but it's
getting to the point where we can no
longer bring those datasets home and
truly experiment in an agile way so what
we're looking at are bringing together
more resources and helping through more
colocation standardization and more
collaboration across our our centers how
can we create those data data archives
and data locations at both compute and
storage or localized on of course our
scientists can query I remotely so to
evolve to a more capable in a more agile
infrastructure like that we're working
with our partners around the agency to
look at I'm sort of new architectures
for that too
so it's a it's a very active topic of
interest yes one of your slides you
showed hypotheses you have a lot of data
out there and you can raise hypotheses
today and well test them against the
data um can you give an example of
concrete example that actually has been
helpful doing this yeah this is often so
when we're posing a hypotheses it's the
ability to approach and prototype around
that that really makes it powerful today
and so we look for prototypes as fast as
possible when someone has a crazy idea
we have this concept of in innovation
vacation at JPL and we'll pull them into
our lab will work with them for one to
two weeks and we'll build out that
hypothesis one example in sort of our
data science from where we've
accomplished that recently is we had
this question so we're sending another
rover to mars in 2020 and we have just
placed curiosity on mars and there was
this hypothesis that all the data we
generated from SL well why can't we
reuse that for this Mars 2020 Rover and
so over a one-week period we gained
access to pull out some of that data
index that in elastic search and present
that on the web for their engineers on
Mars 2020 to start in real time
searching interacting and finding data
that that they can reuse and what makes
that hypothesis sort of how we
substantiate our approach to that is by
having a deliverable that people can use
and looking at the metrics on how that
is used so in that case that's been a
fairly successful successfully tested
hypotheses that we can liberate and help
our engineer search and engage in and
rate through some of that data as often
as possible we will foul on those
hypotheses as well um that's often less
than a week or two but it's the ability
to pose a crazy idea bring in some new
technology and deliver something as
quickly as possible that we try and
simplify
I was curious about what portions a
scientist engineers at NASA are actually
using Python or PI data and how I got it
could be more relevant to them how PI
data can be more relevant to them um
it's a topic we're thinking about quite
a quite a bit what we had a Peter and
and some of the folks from continuum by
JPL a couple months ago I think we had
just about a standing-room-only event
there so the interest is really high
we're engaging them more by bringing in
things like our internal notebook viewer
now so we have a place to point folks to
where they can really quickly see the
the power of on what we can do in a
couple lines of high-level code using
some of these libraries further
diminishing that barrier we're bringing
in new things like wakari now so we have
not just a hosted place to look but a
host in place to execute as well once we
have that kind of infrastructure in
through outreach through i sharing some
of the tools that we've created um and
you know more traditional means as well
like more talks and and more direct on
marketing if you will inside of our
agency I think we're going to be pretty
successful there are a lot of people
that are really interested and so on our
team were incubating some of those tools
that they'll be able to use some they
can others in the next few weeks all
right so that how about we all get some
lunch thank